[Music]
okay is everybody on great awesome looks
like we're all here thank you guys so
much for joining us the meeting
shouldn't take too long we're just gonna
get started up soon I just want one
second I'm just gonna grab Alex we can
see your pajamas your video is still on
oh sorry yeah are we all kind of wearing
pajamas though Karen you mentioned you
had an update from the Commerce team
okay but I actually made the best banana
bread recipe ever last night you're on
you we can't hear you sorry I was muted
as I was saying that is super important
that you guys do know
oh my god did you guys just hear that
Lucy barb do you guys want to see her oh
[Music]
my god she's so cute
we'll be going G from the red well what
do I know
okay if I could just chime in for one
sec here Darrin it's too loud man
Darrin you have to turn your headphones
down you're yelling Oh mom I'm on a
business call hi mom
Molly do you always look like that or
are you just using a filter oh no no
this is just I can't believe you know
Sam I think you said you had some stuff
from the data team yes that's me hi
everyone sorry
[Music]
thank you guys how's it going uh yeah
anyways data teams working on improving
analytics Oh where'd he go maybe the
postman arrived uh anyways wait mark are
you in San Francisco right now I don't
know how that happened I'm not sure I'm
not in San Francisco I'm in my home I
don't know how to work this now you're a
potato
oh is that potato
still nobody can hear what I'm saying at
all nothing coming through